[Music]
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less
my name is joshua fields milburn and i'm
here with my
emmy nominated best friend
ryan nicodemus
how does it feel to be friends with an
emmy nominated person i'm honored to be
in your presence
not only are we new york times
bestsellers oh we have all the laurels
who's laurel
all right we're gonna have some fun
today but first
something serious
our good friend tk coleman known to many
of you as the third minimalist from time
to time
he was recently struck by a car
during an evening stroll through his
neighborhood
and
well he almost died he certainly could
have but thankfully he was rushed to the
hospital and
and he survived and now a month after
the crash
he's back on the minimalist podcast to
talk about
the benefits of near-death experiences
then this thursday on the minimalist
private podcast tk ryan and i are going
to talk about political clutter
and because all three of us have
different political beliefs we'll debate
some touchy subjects that we don't
usually talk about well we never talk
about in public but we'll talk about it
on the private podcast you can check
that out at patreon.com
the minimalist your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free ladies and gentlemen
tk coleman is in the studio today
[Applause]
what's happening y'all it's gonna be
back well you were in a uh emmy
nominated film we'll have some fun with
that real quick so our last film les is
now
uh which came out netflix last year i
got the email last week and they said
hey you're nominated for an emmy i'm
like who's sending this joke email to me
right
but it turns out that it is true there's
nothing you can do as a listener if
you're listening there's nothing to vote
on or anything like that if we win we
win if we don't we don't but how awesome
is that that we have the opportunity to
share the film with more people because
it's going to add a brand new spotlight
this year on less is now but let's be
honest if we win what does it really
mean for us josh
pure true
unadulterated happiness
for the rest of our lives
right so if we don't win i have to be
depressed yeah you must be and the fact
that you can't be happy until we do win
oh my goodness i do want to say thanks
real quick to matt diavel our director
chris and jacob and the whole team over
at booklight yeah and we'll say thanks
to evan and everyone else like evan
helps the lighting in the studio in fact
he was just here a few moments ago
tweaking some of the lighting here in
the studio because you can see we are in
our new
abyss
of a studio it's just the black
background it's actually uh 7 thousand
square feet that we're sitting in right
now you can't tell them optical illusion
and evan helped light this and uh he lit
the last film as well and
uh podcast sean jordan everyone else who
contributed to the film we are so
grateful for that but yeah today is a
special day ryan because people want an
emmy nominee
way more special than that yeah
this alabama do we have something for tk
because
today
is tk's 11th appearance yes on the
podcast time tk unbelievable think about
the number 11. who has 11 rings oh my
gosh
is this is this my bill russell day this
is your bill russell day today oh man we
have 11 rings
the tk coleman you got to put them all
on you got to worry about this
the whole
i need them back after because ella
needs them back
um but we have we need the photo so
jordan here's what i want you to do if
you're watching the video version here
on youtube
i want you to put up a photo right over
here next to tk as he's putting these on
of course with bill russell wearing his
11 rings as the great michael jordan
philosopher of happiness he is says it
don't mean a thing
if it ain't got that rain
you know i was thinking when you talked
about the emmy i was like if you win
this emmy that means you only need five
more to be happy that's right no we need
the egot
i was hoping that we so an e god is if
you get an emmy
a g which is a grammy yep uh oh oscar t
tony yes and i just want to be nominated
for all of those and lose i want to be
the first ever egot nominee look at this
we got to look at oh my goodness you
look like thanos
just don't snap your fingers with those
i guess
hey rings can't buy happiness but they
certainly can amplify the happiness you
are
well let's uh let's let's turn this into
a championship worthy episode today tk
let's do it man we're going to pivot
here thank you for this whole time you
are
like no definitely
danny got some photos of you we're good
there danny unknown with uh with the
photos so you'll be able to see that on
tk's instagram he's at official tk
coleman on instagram podcast john i'll
put a link to that in the show notes but
all three of us have had a near-death
experience within the last eight years
ryan had one eight years ago i had one a
couple years ago and i had another one
again this year and uh a big health
scare but we'll talk about those a bit
on the private podcast this week but i
really wanted to open it up for you
today tk
you told this story the long version
during our chicago event just last week
we did an event in chicago with you but
i thought for our
broad podcast audience here you could
give us a concise version
of what happened because you had a
legitimate
near-death experience and then we've got
some questions here we'll tap into to
talk about some of the lessons that you
learned from that whole thing
yeah man so my wife and i we like to go
for walks every day and so one night we
took a walk and it's funny because
my wife didn't actually want to go for a
walk that night and i pushed the issue i
was like we really should get out
tonight i just got a feeling i need to
be out there on the street tonight oh my
goodness so listen to your wife
so we went for a walk and we were
crossing this intersection where the
person who was making a left they were
they were getting onto the freeway
entrance and um man they you know i had
the right of way they didn't yield i i
you know i don't think they really saw
me or what was going on but um next
thing you know man i just got smacked by
an suv
um and it was just a weird crazy
experience because you don't know until
you're in a moment like that
how many thoughts you can have in a
single second you know and and they say
things like your life flashes before
your eyes there's a glimpse of truth to
that because
you go through so many things you you
deny that this is happening you
you uh just know that this is gonna end
and it's just gonna be a kind of thing
where you're annoyed by somebody and
then i also i mentioned this when we're
in chicago
when i was in fifth grade i was talking
too much in gym class and my teacher at
the time gave me as a punishment i had
to write a one-page paper and i was like
well what's my topic because he would
always give us these crazy topics to
just send us on a runaround and he says
pedestrians safety i was like man that's
stupid
like this dude is making me write this
just to mess with me you know um and so
as that moment's happening i'm thinking
about that fifth grade paper i'm like i
should have paid attention to what he
wanted me to write about but anyway
yeah it was crazy but i think my wife
was with me because um without her there
i'm pretty confident it would have ended
up a lot worse because
she she called 9-1-1 and was able to get
someone there but more importantly the
driver didn't seem to be aware that they
hit me but was more responsive to my
wife screaming
and and so when you considered that it
was a freeway entrance and there was a
decent amount of traffic out that night
if that driver would have kept going
which seemed to be what was gonna happen
um
then there's no doubt that that
the succession of traffic would have
would have resulted in something a lot
worse than what it turned out to be but
thankfully my wife got the driver to
stop
and call 9-1 and uh you know the emt
came and took me away to the hospital
and uh and there they um at the er they
proceeded to treat me like a drug addict
who deliberately threw myself in front
of a car to get some drugs because i was
begging for some pain relief oh my god
for the longest time i must have like
begged six people you know when i came
to i must have been like six different
people to give me some drugs i was like
please i don't want to be in pain i
don't want to want drugs but i'm hurting
give me something yeah but they were
super hesitant and you actually not to
go on too deep of a tangent but you
actually said something about that that
kind of made sense that i hadn't thought
about i don't know if you want to yeah
ryan and i grew up in dayton ohio it's
the
opioid capital of america it's where
i-70 meets i-75 so it's sort of this
the perfect place to traffic these these
drugs but a lot of them end up in
dayton as well overdose capital yeah
like more overdoses per capita than any
other that's right in the country yeah
and ryan
he and i were talking about this
recently he knows people have smashed
their hand into a car door just to go to
the hospital to get opioids because
they're out they don't have access to
them and so it is
it's prevalent and ryan and i know lots
of people who have overdosed oh my gosh
including ryan himself who he talked
about that and a lot of people use
things
and we know people who have died from
overdoses as well
and and so
it's a huge problem so i understand why
they were skeptical but at the same time
and you know i also have to wonder
whether or not there was a racial
component to to that as well but um yeah
you're showing up there you're obviously
in pain you just got hit by a car thank
god you didn't go under the car and you
were able to go on top yeah because had
you gone under totally different story
yeah we'd be interviewing michelle right
now instead of you whoo yeah and that
would not chills i'm so grateful that
you're here i'm grateful you were there
that evening because
it's so precious man you and i had a
conversation
right after it happened
and the thing we talked about and to me
this is the big benefit of
a near-death experience is realizing
that everything after that is all bonus
time oh yeah
and when ryan almost died back in 2014 a
few years ago when i almost died you
realize like this could be the end but
of course it doesn't take that
experience it could always be the end so
for all of us any of us listen it
doesn't take a near-death experience
but sometimes that near-death experience
shows us just how important it is
to live and i want to dive into some of
our audience questions here today
because i think they'll illuminate a lot
of sort of what you went through there
and allow you to expand on that story a
bit so let's start with a question here
from linda on twitter in your moment of
crisis what mattered the most to you
in that moment i remember
waking up in a panic in the em emt going
where's my wife where's my wife
um because she needed to stay behind to
you know do the police report and all
that kind of stuff but i didn't know
what was going on and i just remember
freaking out being like where's my wife
so i think
the first thing is
just
who you love and who you're with because
when when you go through any kind of
hardship physically or psychologically
life reduces down to one thing like who
is in your corner in that moment right
like who loves you who's with you who
who are you going to go through this
with because you don't have any answers
to questions like you have things
running through your mind like oh my
gosh what do i look like right now
right like like seriously like what do i
look like right now um is there anything
wrong with me uh
you know do i have the ability to get
back up and walk is this
more dramatic than i fear is this less
dramatic than i fear
am i going to be good what's going to
happen next you have a lot of questions
but what matters the most in that moment
is like
who knows about me who gives an account
for me who's with me as i go through
this that was the main thing that was on
my mind like if you want the first
thought right your near-death experience
involved your wife she was in the car
with you when you flipped over several
times yeah someone ran you off the road
in washington state
inadvertently and it wasn't some like
big
advertising agency trying to take you
out no
you think advertisements suck or
someone's flipping your car
[Laughter]
but what were you thinking of what were
you thinking of because i i felt the
same way to me my near death both of my
near-death experiences
were and i've probably had more than
that but the two that really stand out
to me
i
it was an ego dissolving experience in a
way sure because at first my my first
thought was
i i i kid you not like is bex gonna be
okay and is ryan going to be okay um
like i want to make sure they're taken
care of but what kind of hubris is that
because it's like oh well i'm i'm
they're they're caregivers no they were
perfectly fine and and able-bodied and
independent on their own without me
but then all of a sudden my huber
started dissolving and it made me
realize of course they're going to be
fine yeah and
and so i'm wondering with you when you
had that experience was there anything
in the moment that you what what was as
linda asks in your moment of crisis what
mattered most to you yeah
man i remember uh so it unfolded where
it was like slushy out it was i see out
um this car tried to pass us going like
80 or 85 miles an hour in slush
and lost control he started to go
towards the median and then he
overcorrected and then came back in
front of us and as he was coming up i'm
like okay tap the brakes like maybe i
can stop this
and then we hit
and him going off the road pulled me off
the road with him so then i'm like it's
okay it's literally out loud i'm saying
it's okay it's okay it's okay it's okay
and then like the back i felt the back
end we got in the dish and i felt the
back end come up and i'm like oh my god
this is not okay
car rolls
and i just remember as it was rolling i
was worried about my head hitting but
like thank god we had seat belts on like
that saved me from like hitting the roof
of the car
um
i was worried about landing and this is
all going through my head like as we're
you know crashing i was worried about
landing upside down like [ __ ] if we're
landing upside down like i don't know
how we're gonna get out of this
and then uh it did a complete flip
landed on its wheels
and i realized like oh thank god like we
landed on our wheels and then um i said
before i looked at mariah i was like are
you okay are you okay and i didn't hear
her say anything so instantly i'm like
oh no like
i had this overwhelming
feeling of like did something hit her in
the head or like does she get injured
way worse than i did
and um
yeah i like and i'm thinking this like
as i'm like starting to look over
towards her and uh she was just like
sitting there and chuck she'd actually
dig it hit the head with a snowboard but
it wasn't like
um concussion you know it wasn't a
concussion or anything just kind of a
bump on her head which now
has taught me to like secure everything
that's in the car it's so funny like you
i had to have that happen to be like oh
like if we're driving with our
snowboards we need to make sure to like
have them as secure as possible so they
don't hit anyone in the head in any way
yeah no it was it was really about um it
was like this denial
then this acceptance
then this like yeah the immediate people
around me
um how you know how are they
how are they gonna take this yeah i
thought about i thought about you i'm
like man that went different i wonder
how josh would have like
reacted to me dying like that would be
so weird like yeah so it was i i agree
like all the people closest to me
i started to
analyze and think about through
different perspectives and situations we
would definitely do a weekend at
bernie's tour oh you died oh yeah
you're getting fully embalmed and going
on
oh please do that that would be so good
here's what i'll tell you though here's
a lesson from both tk and ryan there and
also i think from my own experience
let me tell you what you don't think
about
you don't think about the material
possessions no you don't think about
the the debt that you have or yeah you
you don't think about the things that
you wanted the society told you you
wanted the car the house the walk-in
closets the designer clothes the logo
was i successful or not
yeah like i'm about to be debt-free
oh you know what there might i would be
interested to hear
from someone who um
felt relief
when they had their near-death
experience i could see that i told you
about this on a private podcast i won't
go into the details here in the public
but there was a moment where i
contemplated it because i had so much
debt back in my 20s
and it involved like well the only way
to get rid of this car payment is to
drive this car off of the cliff
basically quite literally not not
metaphorically but literally and so the
point is that you don't start thinking
about the things that you think are
important and the things that are
important invert immediately and the
things you've been forsaking
is the thing that you often think about
which leads me perfectly into
shannon's question shannon from patreon
has something for us how did tk's
near-death experience change his
relationships
there hasn't been a whole lot of time
yet so anything that i say remains to be
tested by time
because it's it's really easy to claim
insight
it's really easy to
uh
purport to have some sort of wisdom but
you know our claims to wisdom have to be
tested by time and how we actually live
so the the ultimate question to that is
i don't know but piggybacking on on what
josh just said
i
i heard somebody say on one of your
recent episodes that if you don't make
time for your wellness you'll eventually
be forced to make time for your illness
and one of the things that it makes me
think about is how
we we hold off
living fully and freely because we have
all of these things that we're worried
about that are part of this story that
we call future right and that that story
is rooted in a presumptuousness of worry
like
we think we have the luxury
of existing tomorrow and the day after
and having all of these you know
limitations and constraints imposed on
us by a future we haven't arrived at and
that we might never arrive at and when
you're in a moment where you go man i i
could have been dead right there you
realize just how fragile that little
story is and how silly it is in many
ways and you realize
man there's so many risks i haven't
taken so many things i haven't said
so many things i haven't tried because
i'm trying to properly distribute my
life over time and i'm saying well i got
time for this and i want to do we save
some things for next week and save some
things for a year from now it's like
life has a way of saying no it's all
right now
and that forces you to really reevaluate
you know
not just why you're living but but how
you're living the choices that you make
so i i think one of the ways that i i
hope it changes my relationships at
least at the level of intention i was
telling my wife this just last night is
i
i tend to not
approach things like
hey it's about us and our journey
together and what we can discover and
explore together and that's something
that i feel very differently about i
tend to be very ambitious and like like
when i heard kobe bryant say um
um friendships come and go but
championship banners hang forever i felt
like i was understood for the first time
i was like i totally get that
bishop's come and go man you know but
championship banners hang forever and
i'm very legacy oriented i'm very hustle
ambition oriented and i i'm very
unlikely to fear regretting not spending
time with family and friends and i'm
more likely to regret not getting after
the projects and goals i want to get
after and i can feel that inverting
because i i just realized in that moment
that hey when you're out of here your
life is nothing more than the story that
other people tell about you when you're
gone that's right life here is all about
investing in that story you know yeah
and those banners if you
have the championship banner but
whatever you did
to get there made you miserable
continuously then was it even worth it
in the first place yeah it's almost like
just a reminder of misery
yeah ryan and i used to have these
presidents club trophies like these big
weapons right
but everything that we you know and
they're like these they're like
statuettes and they're they're shimmery
and shiny yeah it looked like a piece of
art kind of ugly art but hey um
corporate art corporate
corporate contemporary art yes
and anyway like everything that went
into that like it's this thing that
you're supposed to be proud of
yeah but in in reality i was like the
director of who gives a crap right like
who really cares like because those
stores that i managed you know 15 years
ago or whatever most of them are closed
or they've changed ownership whatever it
is like even the banners
on a long enough timeline they come out
of the rafters
right the building falls down yeah
people forget about you right and so
even the people who are legendary
they're only legendary for the last two
thousand years jesus or lao zoo or
confucius or muhammad
or the buddha
but go back and forth
who's legendary from 10 000 years ago
yeah no one right obviously and so like
10 000 years from now will any of us be
legendary and how much does that even
matter what does matter
is not necessarily it's okay to work for
legacy or whatever
but when it continuously pulls us out of
the moment
then our whole life is wasted in a way
but by the way i mentioned kobe bryant i
watched his funeral my wife and i
watched his funeral together and one of
the interesting things is because he had
that legacy right the five championships
the mvp award he had all the accolades
almost every meaningful story that
people told about him this was so
interesting to me it was about a flaw
that he had it was about an imperfection
it was about stuff like you know shaq
making the joke about how he told kobe
there's no i in team and kobe says yeah
but there's a m and a e in there for me
right when kobe is alive that was an
annoying part of him that him and shot
got into arguments about when he died
shaq talked about that moment and
everybody laughed at it and it was
clearly meaningful to him several people
told stories about kobe calling them up
at two in the morning asking about
basketball tips and how they dealt with
problems on the court and they all
during the moment when he was alive when
they got that call they were like dude
do you have to call me at two and two in
the morning to talk about basketball but
when he died that was the meaningful
moment and so when we live we we have
all these elements of perfection that we
try to achieve because we think it's
that perfection that makes our life
valuable but the things that people love
about us the things that people remember
the most about us the stories they're
gonna tell when we die it's the quirky
stuff it's the stuff that makes us
unique it's the stuff that's not about
our perfection but it's the stuff that
makes us human that touched us and that
made us think that made us laugh that
made us angry at you that's the stuff
that we really hold on to so a lot of
the perfection that we seek in legacy
isn't even the reason that we're going
to be talked about when we're gone um
let's answer a question from rico on
facebook
do near-death experiences result in any
deeper insights or enlightenment
you know it's funny um i'm gonna read
this article real quick from
kapil gupta who has had a tremendous
effect on my life since my first
near-death experience it really opened
me up and i think that not necessarily i
don't think it's self-evident that a
near-death experience will lead you to
a new way of doing things or it may for
a short period of time but then things
change and so this is an essay we'll put
a link to this in the show notes as well
it's called a glimpse of death opens a
man's eyes
the wisdom behind the creation of human
life omitted a very important element
death
day-to-day existence is too
accommodating too comfortable
it lulls us into complacency we become
too much at ease with our life too
accustomed to our surroundings too much
part of a fabric
we are here for only a short time but we
live sprawled across the scaffolding of
our lives
as if we are going to be here forever
and because we feel this way
we have no appreciation for life
none
everything is so easy to take for
granted
the human being by virtue of his most
prevalent mental state is a creature of
the twelfth hour
because he forever lives within 11 59 he
rarely feels the urgency
of 12 o'clock but occasionally
something shakes him
a sudden death
a calamity of some sort brings things
into sudden perspective
he is shaken from his complacency
and he is forced to confront the moment
that's what happened to you ryan it's
what happened to utk eventually this is
the time where you can't be outside the
present moment you're not thinking about
the future anymore yeah you are right
here
right now and it's unfortunate that it
requires you to be for something like
this to happen yeah return to text but
eventually
the drama of the event fades
and so does he
back into his well-worn existence
because we become so seduced by inertia
few of us ever
really
live
every human being would be blessed to
experience a near-death experience every
six months
this would keep him on the edge
feeling close to death makes one
immediately feel close to life
the inertia suddenly disappears and the
human being breathes for the first time
in years
he sees the greenery of the grass and
the hardness of the floor and the slow
and gentle movement of the clouds he
discovers that
he is alive after all
he discovers that before he is anything
else he is first and foremost a living
organism
a piece of life
ryan you're a piece of life
thanks
coasting through life without anything
to shake us from our reverie is a curse
we proceed through our daily existence
as programmed zombies bound by habit and
enslaved by emotion
imagine with all your heart for the next
five minutes that you are going to die
at 11 pm tomorrow night
that these would be the last 24 hours of
your life
try it what do you immediately discard
as ridiculous luxuries of the zombified
life
what do you immediately cherish how does
your existence change
it is only under the prospect of death
that we begin to live
an abundance of life binds
an abundance of life
blinds us to its gift
it is too much in supply
thus
we do not cherish it
the vast majority of us human beings
are already dead
it takes nothing less than the power of
death
to compel us to live
it's um
we talked about this on a
a private podcast recently ryan about
near life experiences
how we go through life
with one after another near life
experience like you almost lived there
like i did my taxes i paid the bills i
watered the plant whatever it was but i
wasn't really there
like i was almost observing
this body doing some things and i was
thinking about what the outcome might be
a day from now a week from now a year
from now 10 years from now what's my
legacy yeah right
and so
i think what kapil
brings to the forefront here with
rico's question
is
yeah
you can certainly
find a profound truth about life when
you declutter the
that sentiment that
i have forever
we'll get to it someday next time
and i catch myself saying that some
sometimes i'll do that someday oh we'll
get around to it eventually oh yeah
sorry i missed you next time but what if
there isn't a next time because at some
point there isn't going to be a next
time yeah so let's appreciate this time
right now
you know makes me think about the words
of king solomon who was said to be the
wisest man to have ever lived he said
it's better to attend a funeral than a
party because although the party's more
enjoyable it is by attending the funeral
that we can perceive and remember our
end and the thing about near-death
experiences is that
they
they strip away the illusion that there
is anything other than a near-death
experience life itself is a near-death
experience and we are always brushing up
against death and so the key isn't
trying to have them or wishing that we
can have them but
increasing our consciousness of the fact
that we are always face to face with
death and we always have near-death
experiences that we don't even know
we're having right because our lives are
being held together by so many variables
that the probability of death is always
higher than the probability of life when
we consider like all the conditions that
have to be met in order for life to be
sustained and you know ryan and i both
talked about with our stories that
initial sense of denial where it's like
this is not happening and that's that's
sort of just like
the
presumptuousness that we have about life
that that couldn't happen to me death
couldn't happen to me we all know in
theory that it's coming for us every
single one of us is gonna die but it
just feels like surely the universe
guarantees me 70 years surely it won't
happen in a way that's so ordinary or so
quick but it's coming for all of us and
none of us know how and when that story
is going to end and so we're always
having a near-death experience and so
how do you live
with that consciousness of the fact that
you're always up against death the
second thing i'll say too is that um
when you have a near-death experience
there's something about staying alive
and winning staying alive that feels
like winning
you know it feels like oh i won right i
defeated death and and that can lead to
the impression that death is a form of
losing that when we die we fail rather
than seeing it as when we die we're
finished and i think about the words of
of ram das who i taught you and i share
him in common as a man that we love
where he says death is not an outrage
it's not evidence that your life fails
short it's not evidence that something
tragic has happened although the people
you leave behind will experience it as
such
death just means
you're finished and your life now
becomes a story that you hand over to
the next generation and you trust them
with it and they will decide what they
do with that treasure but we're all
going to die and when that day comes
that won't mean that we have failed that
that we didn't live up to what life was
really about
dr zach bush he's a medical doctor a
triple board certified medical doctor
and
he said in fact i want to get him on the
podcast to talk about this
he he looks at death as the ultimate
upgrade
and uh
i think that maps on to different
religious contexts as well but even him
looking at from a non-religious context
like it is the
the finish line right and we don't know
where that finish line it's like we're
running a race
and we don't actually know when it's
over yeah until it's over right because
as tk just said like yeah we would like
to believe that i'm going to live to 115
and then i'm going to turn in my things
on the last day and then it's over and
i'll just sort of dissolve into the
ether but as tk found out as you found
out
no sometimes it could be like that yeah
and now i'm
gone
we're gonna get to our callers on the
maximal episode this week so if you have
a question comment for our podcast give
us a call 406 219
eight three nine or email a voice memo
to podcast at theminimalists.com we're
not doing a live stream this week
because we were in here early
re-suiting retooling the studio to make
it look beautiful but we'll get back to
that next week ryan what time is it you
know what time it is it's time for the
lightning round josh where we answer our
audience's text messages you can text
your questions your comments your smart
remarks your concerns you can text all
those to
zero two 937-2025
six five four now tk you know those
texts go to both ryan's and my phones we
should set ryan up with that we're out
with we use an app called community
and um we should we should set tk up
with it yeah yeah he always mixes us up
yeah he does that's easy did i say ryan
yeah yeah i mean you guys look the same
yeah um wait wait
you said you could text concerns yeah
concerns smart remarks planned
my grandmother's story
oh my grandma's story uh if you want an
example of a concern to text us about
uh you know what i will
i will tell it on the private podcast
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna embarrass
around the public on the public podcast
anyways what we do during the lightning
round we try to answer the questions
with a short shareable less than 140
character response
we put the text to these minimal maxims
in the show notes so you can copy and
share our pithy answers on social media
if you like and now you can find all of
our minimal maximums in one place thanks
to our good friend jessica lynn williams
she puts them over there at minimal
maxims.com and we do also send you if
you're on our text list every monday
morning
we will send you a monday morning
minimal maxim just because we like the
alliteration we start your week off with
a little bit of simplicity so we we take
any of our pithy sayings and we send you
something special on monday mornings
miriam has a question for us
i've heard some people change their
attitudes towards things like money
after they felt close to dying have tk's
ideas towards minimalism changed at all
well before we get to tk's idea ryan do
you have something pithy for us i do uh
here's the pithy answer the world's
richest dead man
is still dead
so what i like about this we're talking
about money you're talking about
intentionality and like i think quite
often we try to amass treasures not
really realizing the why behind it
what am i supposed to do i'm supposed to
get more money more more more more more
more until i'm dead with more yeah you
know it's interesting because i could
see
if tk was in that mindset of more and
more more and more and more i could see
where like maybe there would be this
realization with simplicity in general
like oh wow like i really spent a lot of
time
you know wasting just so i could have a
bunch of things that now i'm gonna have
to leave behind but you know as as a
minimalist
for me like i don't see how that could
if anything like when
the car was flipping
what was going through my head was like
man like this sucks but if i die
like i felt like
i felt like i had lived a good life up
to that point yeah i didn't have any
regrets i didn't have any
you know any traumas come up or anything
it was just more about like uh oh wow
this sucks but hey man you had a good
run right and now after everything after
this so
we finish one of the the chapters and a
lot of people use things
uh jason and jennifer kirkendall's story
what am i going to do with this newfound
freedom
because
you've closed that chapter and it's like
almost like you have a new birthday in a
way yeah the day that you almost died is
like a rebirth
in some way and everything after that is
that bonus time that we were talking
about
absolutely i can tell you something that
truly did die in me it wasn't a near
death it was a real death
that is the desire to prove myself by
outworking anybody on this earth i can
give you the formula for completely
destroying me in any competitive context
show up and work 80 hours a week because
i'm never competing with you for that
never again like i've lived that life
of being the last to leave the first to
show up i know what it means to be the
favorite co-worker the favorite employee
i know what it means to be the person
that's willing to put his body on the
line say yes to everything and just go
all out in the name of winning social
capital in the name of making money and
that is completely dead in me because
man when it is over
all that really matters is how much time
you spent
living in a way that you actually
believed in living in a way that you
loved and that you're proud of and that
will cause other people to tell the
stories about you that you truly want to
be told
and for me it it makes me step back and
say man okay
we look at money as this permission
granter where we have ways that we want
to live and money gives us permission to
really say yes what we want to say yes
really say no what we want to say no and
you start to realize like you know what
you can actually say yes to what you
want to say yes to and you can say no to
what you want to say no to without the
money it's not it's not that money gives
you the permission to say things it's
that
money sometimes softens the blow of
having to deal with the consequences of
owning who you want to be in the world
but you can own who you want to be with
or without the money you can say no you
know what i don't feel like doing that
and i'm not doing it and someone may say
well fine i'll take away this paycheck
take it away whatever pain i have to
experience i'll experience it but one
thing i'm going to do in this life i'm
going to own myself and i'm going to
show up and do whatever the hell i want
to do like derrick sivir says if it's
not a hell yes it's a hell no and like
i'm i'm all in on that now
and at the same time we don't want to
renounce the early work or the hard work
or whatever else because that's another
form of clinging or renunciation and so
now it's not like well you know what i'm
never going to show up at work before
noon now it's like right like i want to
show up before noon but as a matter of
religious belief i'm going to renounce
that now right yes silly where it's like
if i feel compelled like some weeks i
feel compelled to work 80 hours
this weekend i'm taking off i'm actually
taking friday through monday off and
that's the first time i've done it in
years um i generally take one day off
every 14 i have like a bi-weekly sabbath
it's on a wednesday but
and when i do that like i tend to work
on weekends and everything else but i
don't do it because
someone else is dictating that i must do
that that's right yeah and i don't
virtue signaling no and it's really what
that like in the corporate world that's
what it it absolutely is look how
valuable i am right for me it's like i
feel so compelled like i would be
miserable if i didn't do this work
because this is the most compelling
thing for me to do yeah but of course we
have to put as beautiful as the music is
there has to be space between the notes
otherwise it's just
noise you can tweet that podcast sean
but by the way the root of the word
culture is cult right and every company
has a culture
which is a set of cult-like behaviors
that seem necessary
in order to be a legitimate
part of that company and so when we go
to our jobs and it's not just our jobs
it's our it's our churches it's our
communities our families we can learn
very quickly that there are behavioral
signals that have a way of announcing to
everyone i'm legit
you can figure out how to read the room
and like what time do i need to show up
to be perceived as legit you know how
busy do i need to look in order to be
perceived as legit you know when i used
to work at the restaurants one of the
things i found out really quickly is the
importance of learning how to look
sufficiently busy because even if you're
working hard if you don't look like
you're working hard you lose a lot of
trust and you lose a lot of respect and
so you learn to play these games of like
all right i'm gonna be productive and
this is what i need to do to be
productive but in addition to that here
are these other things i need to do in
order to make sure that i'm looking as
productive as i actually am because i
can be productive but if i don't look
sufficiently productive people won't
trust me anymore but and you get caught
up in playing these different types of
games that you find yourself following a
cult that doesn't reflect the person
that you want to be and one of the
things i love that seth godin says is
always ask yourself who am i becoming in
the process of playing these games
yeah because if i'm playing the the
wrong game i'm becoming the wrong
version of myself i don't mean morally
wrong but i mean
if i'm playing the game that i think i'm
supposed to play because everyone else
around me is playing it yeah but that
game is not for me then it's turning me
into a version of myself that i don't
want to become you're winning the game
but losing yourself yeah or we like lie
to ourselves and say like we see
everyone playing the game and we're like
oh we're gonna play it differently
we're gonna it's gonna be different for
us yeah i'm gonna play it differently
and that that's where i was in the
corporate world it's like hey i
i'm following the same recipe but surely
i'm gonna bake a different cake exactly
as soon as i take this thing out of the
oven you know it's not going to taste
the same exact way everyone else who
followed this recipe of course no it's
you get that same result and it's fine
if that's the result that you want if
that's the arrival that you're looking
for but then quite often what happens is
we have our ladder leaned against the
wrong building we've been climbing so
long
it's like almost as though like we just
need to fall off and realize like oh i
was climbing it took the fall for me uh
to realize like oh
i was
my ladder was leaned against the wrong
building this whole time yeah but we get
so far up it's like well it's scary to
go down i guess i'll just keep climbing
up yeah i guess i'm supposed to keep
playing this game i've already gotten so
far it's like if you ever read a book
that you dislike but you've made it 200
pages in and i i guess i have to finish
it i tried to walk out of the new batman
movie recently
because i thought i was like this i just
don't i don't i don't dig this at all
that's right yeah and it was i was like
we already committed an hour and bex was
like i kind of like it i'm like okay
i'll stay for you but like
we'll we're happy to walk out in the
middle of a movie oh we've walked out of
movies before man yeah yeah in fact i
think you're no that's not true i've
walked out on a movie with someone else
before but
as far as like number of times i've
walked out the majority have been with
you which i appreciate because it's like
you're 20 or 30 minutes into something
and you're like dude are you enjoying
this i'm like nah not really he's like
yeah me either let's go that's a
superpower the willingness to walk away
is a personal super power that anyone
can harness i have two pithy answers for
you
we waste our lives
scared to death of death
we're scared to
live our life
because we're scared that something bad
might happen
and if something bad happens to me it
says something to me about a person so
we die these little tiny deaths
over and over right we die the thousand
deaths and we're actually going to talk
about this a bit on the the private
podcast about the things that we worry
about that are outside of our control
calls these daily little deaths
in us one more pithy thing for you
near-death experiences help us avoid
near-life experiences
which i think sums up this whole episode
here because if we walk through life
not really living we're having these
near life experiences but if we open
ourselves up to the potential that we're
going to die and sometimes it actually
requires that near-death experience then
maybe we can avoid the complacency the
apathy the
the being extracted from the moment
because we're constantly staring in the
rear view i wish i would have done this
differently i wish i would have done
this better i wish i would have been a
better person why wasn't i good back
then why did i make that mistake why did
i fail
we're looking in the rear view or we're
looking so far on the horizon what's my
legacy what is what are they going to
think about me 10 generations from now
that we're not looking right in front of
us and that causes all these other types
of accidents if you're driving your car
you're always looking in the rear view
you're going to crash if you're driving
your car you're always looking at the
mountain in the foreground you're going
to crash but if you're right here right
now and you're looking
at what's in front of you then you're
actually here in the moment and it's
okay to glance in the rear view it's
okay to look off on the horizon but you
do that too much
and you're gonna crash
speaking of uh right here right now
here's one thing that's going on in the
life of the minimalist we had to
reschedule something ryan and i had a
flight that got canceled we're getting
ready to fly out to tennessee we're
working on this charity project or this
philanthropic project with our friends
from ramsey education ryan and i are
from dayton ohio and we've done 10
different philanthropic projects over
the last decade or so
and our most recent one is we're trying
to provide financial literacy education
to every middle and high school student
in and around dayton ohio so montgomery
county area right so not just in the
dayton public schools but that whole
area because
that's something they don't teach us in
school
until now yeah it's funny i the closest
thing i had to it was uh it was like a
home type elective class so it wasn't
required it was just something that
you know i i think i already had like
two or three study halls and the council
was like no dude no more study halls you
have to pick an elective so i just went
to the easiest thing on the list
and uh they did a budgeting class and i
just remember how 50 of the budgeting
was all about debt payments mortgage car
payment credit card payment it was like
yeah it was crazy getting yourself in
debt yes it blows my mind like i don't
know why
this isn't a standard piece of
curriculum in in middle schools and high
schools like showing kids how to stay
out of debt
and the value of of uh of cash basically
well thankfully 25 of high schools in
america have now taught this curriculum
it's called the foundations in personal
finance what we're trying to do is we're
trying to bring that curriculum to every
middle school student every high school
student in and around dayton ohio to
teach them about personal finance teach
them about debt and about avoiding debt
not borrowing from their future avoiding
debt when they go to college yeah
getting a debt-free degree right yeah
and then of course if you're gonna get a
mortgage 15-year fixed rate don't take
on anything you can't afford
understanding a budget understanding how
to earn income
we don't talk about these things in
school and that's why this is so
critical thank you and so we're trying
to help out if you want to contribute
you can it's the minimalists.com
education you can see a little bar there
we're over halfway to our goal already
it's incredible it's incredible here's
an incredible stat for you tk the
average american household is in debt
ninety seven thousand seven hundred and
fifty dollars in non-mortgage debt
non-mortgage debt that's insane yeah so
yeah by helping us fill this bar all the
way up imagine all the years of
suffering we'll be able to like save
these kids from that's amplified by debt
that's exactly and so we're going to go
over to ramsey solutions on june 13th
you can join us there for a free event
we'll be there with hugs maybe we can
even drag tk out there for that we'll
bring hugs and conversation we're also
going to be on the ramsey show and some
other shows there 2 p.m
on june 13th you can find all the
details at the
minimalists.com
tennessee you can come on out it's free
you just have to register there
beforehand so they know that you are
coming we'll give you a hug we'll talk
to you we'll take some pictures we'll
have some fun for free and if you want
to contribute the minimalists.com
education you can contribute there 25
provides a year of curriculum for one
middle school student 45 dollars for a
high school student if you want to
contribute more than that great or if
you could just contribute five dollars
that'd be wonderful too anything you can
do helps us help these kids not borrow
from their future hey man personal thank
you guys to participating this and big
shout out to ramsey as well
you know c.s lewis says good philosophy
must exist if for no other reason then
that bad philosophy does and i believe
that financial literacy education must
exist if for no other reason than that
poverty producing ideas dominate our
society we may not teach our kids about
investing about wealth management but
they will definitely learn whether we
teach them or not some really bad ideas
about debt consumerism and so on because
they're constantly being bombarded with
these things and so one of the hardest
things to do when you achieve financial
freedom is to look back and remember
with empathy the people that haven't
achieved that financial freedom and to
say how can i give back in the form of
insight in the form of knowledge and the
form of mentorship
in a way that helps other people achieve
their financial potential money isn't
everything
but if you don't understand how it works
and if you don't acknowledge that it is
something something very important then
it does become everything to you because
you become a slave to bad ideas
surrounding it
very well said i know uh some people
have some criticism about dave ramsey
and we're actually going to talk about
that this week on our political clutter
episode on the private podcast we have
some really interesting we have some
wild wild questions and we'll get to
that we'll also talk about why we've
partnered with dave ramsey on this and
address some controversy and some some
criticism over there and i will say
fundamentally regardless of what you
think of of dave and the team over there
what we're simply trying to do here
is help some kids yeah this isn't about
josh it's not about tk it's not about
ryan it's not about dave it's about
kids in dayton ohio and changing their
future for the better by helping them
avoid all the pitfalls that we were
dragged through
uh throughout our 20s and even into our
30s trying to get rid of all of that
debt that we got ourselves in oh my
goodness yeah real quick by the way you
know like you said some people have
criticisms of dave ramsey it's like so
first some people have criticisms of
those critics right uh secondly i'm
always amused when people say i don't
agree with everything that he says
because that seems to imply that there's
someone out there for whom that is not
true is there some human being out there
no for whom you agree with everything
they say that really should be the
default that doesn't need to be said
whether we're talking about dave ramsey
my father or myself the default should
be i don't believe everything that he
says because he is a human being who is
in the process of learning and will
freely admit that there are things he
knows today that he didn't know
yesterday so yeah that's the default
that doesn't need to be spelled out i
mean i think a lot of people push that
out there like i don't agree with
everything he says
as a way of apologizing the fact for the
fact that they have chosen to learn from
someone that's a human being that
another person may have a problem with
but man i don't apologize for learning
anything from anyone if you've got
something valuable that can help make me
free i'm gonna take that knowledge
no apologies to anybody for who i choose
to learn from preach it's funny one of
the best compliments that i get is when
someone will come up to us at a in the
hug line or at an event they're like you
know what i listen to you and josh all
the time i agree with about half of what
you say and you know the joke is like
it's my half
right everything that i say right but of
course that's not what they mean but but
it's a good compliment because i'm like
oh great like you're you're taking in
what we're saying
and you're forming your own opinion and
that's what this is all about it's not
about following a recipe
it's about creating your own recipes so
um yeah i don't agree with yeah i don't
agree with anything with everything that
anybody says right including myself yes
including myself if you go back we have
400 podcast or 342 podcast episodes i'm
going to disagree with myself on a large
portion of those and what does that mean
i mean that signals growth right yeah
the willingness to walk away even from
my old ideas
certainly from old beliefs and opinions
if we cling to those things they're
going to drag us in all of these
directions in which we don't want to be
dragged and so yes tk you bring up a
great point it should be self-evident to
us that i don't agree with this person
whoever it is tk coleman ryan nicodemus
dave ramsey joshua fields melbourne i
don't agree with everything they say
well no kidding
because they're a human being they're an
individual with beliefs opinions
cultural influences societal influences
dogma
but also they have a different
understanding of the world than i do and
that's what makes life beautiful we'll
talk about that more on the private
podcast but come see us if you are
anywhere in or near tennessee or you
just want to make the road trip the
minimalists.com
tennessee will be there on june 13th at
2 p.m we'll see you there alabama what
else you got for us here are some
voicemail comments and insights from our
listeners
hey there this is mckinley calling from
oklahoma city i just had a tip for the
other listeners i went going through my
closet
noticed that a lot of things i held on
to just in case and so i decided to
upcycle and repurpose my clothes so i'm
not a dress person i ended up taking a
lot of my dresses and cutting them into
tops and then using the bottom part for
creative things like headbands and tube
tops and skirts and all kinds of things
and then going through my clothes for
donations the things that i didn't want
to repurpose or didn't need to hold on
to i put into a bag and i stayed for a
closing trade party with my friends so
all of us go through our clothes and get
donations and then sit around and
exchange them that way we know they
don't go into landfills and that we are
living sustainably
hey josh ryan it's jack from the bay
area here in california just calling in
because i wanted to comment on rasheed
from massachusetts comment
about
choosing whether to
keep things in storage
for his retirement home
something me and my wife recently did
was we let go of a couch that we had
been gifted
not by actually selling it or giving it
away but by actually asking a friend to
hang on to it
and potentially give it back to us if
later in life we were to find a two or
three bedroom apartment or house here in
the bay that we could use it so it was a
win-win our friend got to borrow a couch
and kind of enhance a kind of movie
style garage and we allowed ourselves to
obtain
more living space in our living room
with a newer couch that we recently
acquired that
works with the aesthetic a little bit
better is a pull out for friends and
family and ultimately just works better
for us now
all right y'all stay tuned for some wild
political questions here in a moment
we're gonna talk about this week's
maximum episode give you some teasers
there but first check out this
thoughtful comment from one of our
lovely patreon subscribers selena says
hello minimalists i finally subscribed
to the private podcast on patreon and
now i can get my other two-thirds of the
show
that's every every week we do a tuesday
episode the tree for the public
advertisement free as well because
advertisements suck and every thursday
we do a deep dive talk about some things
we wouldn't talk about in public it's
usually about twice as long as the
minimal episode so maximum episode is
completely separate but it will play in
your favorite podcast app so selena
thank you for saying that she says it
feels better than getting my recommended
daily dose of veggies
selena i'll tell you this our show has
fewer carbs absolutely i wonder what
paul paul saladino would say about her
comment
mr carnivore he would say that our
podcast is less filling but
more fufilling yes exactly yes for added
value this week i wanted to
talk to you about a terrifying look at
our near our near future that is filled
with near-life experiences
but
uh us not living a whole lot there's
this book a novel that just came out by
dave edgars and i know danny unknown
just started it but i just finished it
it's called the every and it's a
follow-up to the the book the circle
which came out in 2013 and there are
like six books i wish i would have
written and the circle is one of those
books and this is a follow-up and it's
even more terrifying it takes place in a
a near future
that is dystopian but
what is the key of dystopian dystopian
is like 98
utopian and it's that two percent of
the dystopia
the two percent of hell that makes it
hell right
because you don't realize it because it
seems it seems like heaven
when you lay it all out but then you get
behind it and you realize it takes all
the life out of life
it turns everything into a near life
experience so it's about a tech company
in the near future in silicon valley
that in san francisco in particular
it's sort of this amalgamation if if
google and facebook merged and then they
bought amazon
this is the every
and
they have sort of taken over the world
and now
all of these ideas begin to permeate all
these apps and it becomes more and more
surveillance state and we all lose
little bits of our freedom not because
they're stolen from us
but why do we lose our freedom we give
it up
right so the book is called the every
we'll put a link to it in the show notes
it's by dave edgar's he he's written
some other amazing books besides the
circle he wrote this great memoir called
a heartbreaking work of staggering
genius
by the way we got a bunch more surprise
questions about political clutter this
week tk here are a few samples for you
who did the minimalists vote for in the
last election
and why did they vote for two different
candidates
ryan how could we possibly be friends
after this yeah how did tk's near-death
experience affect his religious and
political beliefs
is my vote worthless i'm considering not
voting is this a privileged position one
of our listeners asks
what do the minimalists think about the
war in ukraine what are the minimalist
thoughts on abortion and roe v wade oh i
can't wait to get into that one
are the minimalists happy or upset that
elon musk bought twitter i think i'm
just gonna let you tk cover this uh
maximal
ryan and i do have radically different
beliefs on all these questions so in
some ways they are perfect and tk
actually has a different belief i think
than both of us and that's why we work
so well with each other we can ping
these ideas off each other without
holding a grudge against one another
yeah plus we got a million more
questions for tk coleman and the
minimalist if you want to hear all that
check out the minimalist private podcast
this week visit patreon.com
the minimalist to subscribe and get your
personal link so that our weekly private
podcast plays in your favorite podcast
app you'll also gain immediate access to
hundreds of hours of archives those
private archives we have over there
recordings of live events exclusive home
tours and our private community of
thousands of open-minded minimizers like
you you can follow the minimalist on
tik-tok instagram facebook and twitter
at the minimalist or follow tk coleman
as well we'll put links to his social
media in the show notes if you want our
podcast show notes in your inbox sign up
for our email list at
theminimalists.com on behalf of ryan
nicodemus tk coleman podcast sean
alabama jordan no more social just danny
unknown post-production peter who's
filling in for podcast sean today
let's give him a round of applause for
being here today
i think we just post production peter is
a long moniker i think
p3 works right yeah post-production
peter yeah p3 works p cubed
i like the alliteration
peter no we're doing pizzas in the house
sean wouldn't give up podcast peter
because of podcast shots
i think it's p3 anyway uh peter thank
you for being here today also emma the
immigrant and the rest of our team i'm
joshua fields milburn if you leave here
today with just
one message
let it be this
[Music]
love people
and use things
because the opposite never
works thanks for listening y'all we'll
see you next time
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
that's just feeding your greed oh i bet
that you'll be fine
without it